Roosevelt once said, “There’s nothing
to fear but fear itself.”
And that’s how you can tell that he’d
never heard of the SCP Foundation, and faced
some of the terrifying nightmares they deal
with on a daily basis.
And today, we’re taking on the frightening
task of comparing and ranking some of the
scariest SCPs out there for your viewing pleasure.
While, of course, fear is a highly subjective
concept, at well over 300 videos into our
tenure, we think we have a pretty good idea
of which SCPs bump hardest in the night.
So to start us off, in the immortal words
of another truly terrifying YouTuber:
Number Fifteen.
SCP-087 is an old favorite, and perhaps one
of the most famous SCPs out there, thanks
to classified information about it being leaked
in a certain video game.
But exposure hasn’t diminished the potent
aura of fear that still lingers at the bottom
of this sinister staircase.
If ever you find yourself in the administrative
building of a university campus, you may suddenly
experience a sense of creeping dread, knowing
that any of the doors around you may lead
you into a living nightmare.
What awaits you is all-consuming darkness
and a seemingly endless descent into the void
below...That is, until the crying starts.
Not long after that, you’ll go from hating
the fact you’re alone in this horrible place
to desperately wishing that were the case.
When 087’s infamous inhabitant, the Face,
comes up to greet you, you might even wish
you’d never been born at all…
But enough about a scary place you might stumble
into.
This next horror comes straight to you.
If you need to take regular nighttime drives,
for business or pleasure, then SCP-1337 is
bound to be your worst nightmare.
She’s whispered about in urban legends all
over the world: The Ghostly Hitchhiker.
She goes by many names, but the only true
name is Mary Talish.
After being murdered and mutilated in an occult
ritual, her ghost would hitchhike down the
roads of Muncie, Indiana, and take rides back
to the home of her parents, before disappearing
without a trace.
A little spooky, but mostly benign.
Until one sadistic Foundation researcher decided
to attempt her neutralization by killing off
her parents.
In absolute contrast to the researcher’s
plans, this turned Mary from a ghost into
a violent demon.
Now taking the form of her own mutilated corpse,
if you see her on the side of the road and
keep driving, your horrible fate is sealed.
She’ll appear in your backseat, her hollow
eye-holes burning with fury.
And when they find your car, crashed on the
side of the road, you’ll be dead and mutilated,
just like her.
But if you think this nighttime drive is frightening,
wait until you take a field trip...
Repeat after us: I do not recognize the bodies
in the water.
SCP-2316 is an anomalous water source, namely,
a large, mist-shrouded lake, and the closer
you get, the more you’ll find yourself unable
to ignore all the bodies floating in the water.
You do not recognize the bodies in the water...Or
do you?
Can you tell if it’s SCP-2316’s powerful
cognitohazardous properties taking hold, or
are those bodies really your old classmates?
The only way to find out is to get closer.
And the closer you get, the more certain you
are: Yes, they really are your old friends!
Why did you leave them here?
It’s been so long.
Don’t you feel guilty for abandoning them?
You get closer.
You’re in the mist now.
All those familiar faces.
The water laps at your ankles.
Knees.
Waist.
Shoulders.
Neck.
You’re smiling.
You recognize the bodies in the water.
They’re your friends.
You’re with them now.
But horror around a dark, misty lake is to
be expected.
During a cheerful night at the theatre?
Not so much...
You’ve been vaccinated, after over a year
of careful social distancing.
So you decide to treat yourself to some live
entertainment: A play being performed by a
local community theater group, The Hanged
King’s Tragedy.
Or SCP-701, as it’s known to the SCP Foundation.
However, your classy evening quickly takes
a turn for the worst and into an absolute
nightmare when a strange bound, hooded figure
appears on the stage.
From there, not only will the content of the
play become more disturbing - from murders
to hangings - but the behavior of the audience
will take an even more depraved turn.
It will erupt into horrifying violence and
chaos, as seemingly normal people go into
a lethal frenzy, driven mad by the cursed
play.
Every performance of SCP-701 is doomed to
become a harrowing mass killing.
Let’s go from the stage to a horror who
prefers to stay out of the limelight...
He waits in the dark.
Pacing, hiding.
Weeping.
If ever you see his face, there’ll be hell
to pay.
That’s right: It’s the infamous Shy Guy,
SCP-096.
From its look to its actions, this homicidal
maniac is built from nightmare fuel.
He’s freakishly tall with disproportionately
long limbs and a gaunt, stretchy face with
a terrifyingly large mouth.
And if ever you see so much as a photo of
that face, you’ll find out exactly what
he can do with it.
SCP-096 will make a beeline for you at breakneck
speeds.
No chasm or barrier or ocean will stop him.
No weapon will slow him down.
He will find you, and he will murder you.
Your family won’t even have any remains
to bury when he’s done.
But you don’t need to look at our next monster’s
face for him to terrify you.
Honestly, he doesn’t even really have one...
First thing’s first: Stay put, and don’t
open the door.
What, do you think we’re just paranoid?
Just be quiet and listen.
Can you hear it?
The deep, labored breathing?
The subtle scratching against the wood?
Even though you can’t see it, you know what
it looks like.
It’s waiting.
Listening.
Its long, dirty teeth chatter with anticipation.
Whatever you do, don’t open the door.
SCP-303, also known as The Door Man, is a
mysterious creature with the ability to manifest
behind doors or other entryway barriers opposite
a sentient observer, always causing such intense
feelings of dread in his victims that they
find it impossible to open the door or entryway
barrier.
This fear is so great that some people have
starved to death rather than open the door
to get food.
He’s just that terrifying.
But you’ll be grateful that 303 was keeping
the door closed, if it means you can avoid
going to our next terrifying location.
We have a few questions for you: First, have
you been having strange dreams lately?
Interesting.
Secondly, do you remember going to a place
called Cragglewood Park in your youth?
It was a strange, wondrous, and slightly unsettling
theme park, full of grinning, singing trees
and the most beautiful carousel you’ve ever
seen.
Just two more questions: Are you an only child?
Have you always been an only child?
If you’ve ever visited SCP-2571, Cragglewood
Park, you may have difficulty answering these
questions - Because this whimsical fever dream
beckons pairs of siblings to its twisted carnival
of smiling trees.
But only one of these two siblings ever leaves,
and the other becomes just one more giggling,
singing nightmare tree.
Sleep tight, kids.
But that’s not the most dangerous entity
coming after your kids.
What are your kids watching?
In an era of unprecedented internet access,
it’s a harder question to answer than ever.
But you better pray they’re not watching
SCP-993, or they’ll end up as prey for a
sinister entity known as Bobble The Clown.
With Bobble, it’s less a question of what
he’ll do to your kids, and more about what
he’ll make your kids do to you, themselves,
and anyone else unlucky enough to cross them
under his influence.
His educational programming will teach your
kids about things like murder, self-mutilation,
cannibalism, performing dark rituals, and
believe us, they will be extremely receptive
to his teachings.
Leave your children with Bobble playing on
the TV, and they’ll be little monsters before
you know it!
But enough about little monsters.
How about a really, really big one.
SCP-1128, also known as the Aquatic Horror,
is a massive underwater predator with unique
infohazardous properties: Once you’ve had
the beast described to you, you’re in its
sights forever, and you’re not safe near
any body of water.
The monster has devoured its victims in oceans,
lakes, pools, bathtubs, puddles, and in the
case of one extremely unlucky victim, the
glass of water he was drinking from.
It’s a ruthless and terrifying predator,
and once it has you, you’ll be gorily devoured
in seconds.
They say the one way to escape it is to take
amnestic treatment and forget you ever knew
about the beast, but does that really make
you feel safe?
Will anything make you feel safe now, next
time you’re straying a little too close
to the water?
But at least SCP-1128 will devour you quickly.
Our next horror loves to take his time.
SCP-106.
The Old Man capable of walking through walls,
burning flesh with a touch, and most terrifyingly
of all, dragging you into his private torture
dimension, where he has absolute power.
There, he’ll taunt and hurt you for as long
as he pleases, until you’re little more
than a desiccated husk.
Once he selects his targets, almost nothing
can stop him in his pursuit of them - save
only for the prospect of causing more suffering
elsewhere.
But while 106 takes his time, our next unstoppable
sadist kills whole extended families at once...
If you plan on having a christening, a wedding,
or a funeral any time soon, well, we hope
you’re prepared to plan for plenty more
funerals.
Especially if your Cousin Johnny is in attendance.
Though the Foundation would be more inclined
to call him SCP-2852.
He’s the ultimate, terrifying party-crasher,
and when he manifests in your family function,
there’s nothing anybody can do to save you.
He turns these sacred days into orgies of
violence and terror.
Arcane rituals, murder, cannibalism, self-mutilation,
and more.
Even if you manage to survive one of these
events, you’ll forever be haunted.
Many die early, all live unfortunate and unhappy
lives, many turn to violence and murder as
they cannot cope with the horrors they’ve
seen.
And worst of all, you never know when it’s
going to be your turn.
After all, Cousin Johnny is everybody’s
cousin.
But when it comes to body horror, Johnny doesn’t
hold a candle to our next entry...
These monsters make your standard walking
dead look positively cuddly.
SCP-610, the Flesh that Hates, is a Sarkicist
nightmare that’s thankfully confined to
a desolate community in Siberia.
But if it ever got out, then dying before
the change took hold would be a happy reprieve.
This hyper-infectious virus transforms you
into a straight-up monster, a fleshy abomination
with only one prerogative: Spread the infection
further.
And if ever you were unlucky enough to be
on the receiving end of 610’s pathogenic
payload, the monster you become couldn’t
even be called a twisted shadow of who you
once were.
The Flesh is Eternal.
It wants to bring us all into its hateful
embrace.
But there is one body horror event more disturbing
than 610.
Why?
Because it went global.
Learn to embrace the dark, friends, fear the
light.
The words that ushered in the incomprehensible
nightmare of SCP-001 - When Day Breaks, an
XK-Class End of the World Scenario where the
sun itself becomes a terrifying anomaly.
Exposure to sunlight caused its victims to
melt, while still remaining alive.
These blobs of living human flesh would then
coagulate into giant, amoeba-like masses,
hell-bent on dragging others out into the
light.
Most horrors on this list lurk in the darkness.
There are few things more profoundly unnatural
than evil not just living in the light, but
being the light itself.
Though true horror can often hide in unlikely
places, just like the next entry on our list...
SCP-4666, the Yule Man.
The king of turning Christmas Cheer into Christmas
Fear, and making Krampus look like jolly old
Saint Nick himself in comparison.
Every year, this Yuletide Monster selects
a new series of victims that he stalks over
the Christmas season, preparing to make his
grand entrance in the very heart of winter.
And when he does enter, if you’re lucky,
he’ll just leave a morbid toy made from
the flesh of his previous victims.
If you’re unlucky, he’ll torture and then
butcher the whole family in ways too horrible
to imagine, before kidnapping the youngest
child.
This child will then be forced into slavery
in the Yule Man’s twisted workshop, and
if he doesn’t eat them when he gets hungry,
he’ll make their fellow children turn them
into toys when they get too weak or injured
to work themselves.
It doesn’t come much more evil than this.
But we can think of one that frightens us
just that little bit more...
SCP-2774, also known as the Slow Burn Sloth.
Surprised?
Perhaps you’ve never even heard of this
one before, and you’re wondering how it
could beat out classics like SCP-096 and SCP-106.
After all, it’s just a memetic image of
a man in a janky sloth costume that sometimes
appears in media, both recorded and live.
But if you do happen to see this strange little
image, everything you hold dear is about to
be taken away from you.
The scariest thing about a lot of the monsters
on this list is the way they’ll kill you.
The scary thing about 2774 is that it won’t
kill you at all - You’ll just wish it had.
When the memetic infection takes hold, you’ll
slowly lose all cognitive functions.
You can no longer move or even think on your
own.
Your body is on slow-motion autopilot for
the majority of the day, save for 150 seconds
every 24 hours.
During those lucid periods, victims will often
beg to be put out of their misery.
The Slow Burn Sloth isn’t gory, shocking,
or sadistic, it’s worse: It’ll trap you
in the prison of your own mind, reducing you
to less than an infant, but fully conscious
of all you’ve lost.
Your own little sunken place, where the only
release is death.
And frankly, SCP Explained Fans, we can’t
think of many things scarier than that.
Now go check out “Waldo Finds You - SCP-4885
- Find Him” and “SCP-2521 ●●|●●●●●|●●|● and
Infohazard SCPs Explained” for terrifying
SCPs!